die nachricht war damals sensationell
ein forschungsteam hat er vor zwei
jahren verkündet spuren von flüssigem
wasser auf dem mars gefunden zu haben
ihr indiz mysteriöse fliesst spuren in
den krater hängen doch jetzt gibt es
neue hinweise die das in frage stellen
demnach sollen die fleece spuren wohl
durch sand entstehen und eben nicht
durch wasser zumindest ist sand
beteiligt wie das forschungsteam aus
arizona darauf kommt was die nasa dazu
sagt und ob die chancen auf leben auf
dem mars kleiner geworden sind jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet wasser gilt als eine
grundvoraussetzung für leben so wie wir
es kennen verschiedene forschungsteams
weltweit fahnden fieberhaft nach
indizien für wasser im weltraum wie zum
beispiel auf dem mars denn dies würde
zum einen die menschliche besiedlung des
roten planeten vereinfachen zum anderen
wäre dies eine grundlegende basis dafür
dass auf dem mars rtn dieses leben
entstehen könnte oder bereits entstanden
ist die raumsonde mars reconnaissance
orbiter lro der nasa hat er vor einiger
zeit messdaten angeliefert deren analyse
bis jetzt als indizien für flüssiges
wasser auf dem mars galten
so hatte ein forschungsteam aus atlanta
vor zwei jahren die these aufgestellt
dass salziges schmelzwasser im mass
sommer wohl regelmäßig die steilhängen
des roten planeten hindert fließe
saisonal auftretende fliesst strukturen
an bestimmten abhängen sollten dies
belegen diese dunklen finger artigen
strukturen an steinen mars krater hängen
werden ihre kühe ins lob linie kurz rsl
genannt zudem hatte das forschungsteam
damals spuren von salzen entlang der
kraterwände entdeckt perchlorat die aus
salzhaltigem wasser stammen könnten und
sich innerhalb der abflussrinnen
abgelagert hätten das wasser selbst
könnte vom eis abschmelzen dass sich
unter dem mars boden befindet der
damaligen vermutung nach könnte es dann
an der oberfläche der kraterwände
heraustreten und herr ablaufen diese
these hat da was für jubel und wirklich
große aufregung gesorgt als sie doch als
fast eindeutiger beweis dafür dass auch
heute noch wasser auf dem mars fließen
könnte doch jetzt gibt es
ernstzunehmende zweifel an dieser these
nach analysen eines forschungsteams aus
arizona stammen die damals entdeckten
fliesst strukturen wohl eher von
abrutschenden sand sand und staub kölner
sollen demnach zu den dunklen streifen
abrutschen ihre these stützen sie auf
ihre beobachtung dass die beobachteten
fliesst strukturen enden sobald die
abhänge für sand zu flach werden zudem
sei eine starke ähnlichkeit zu
denjenigen rinnen zu erkennen die sich
hier auf der erde auf samt dünnen finden
lassen das forschungsteam stützt sich
dabei auf neue kamera aufnahmen der nasa
maßnahme insgesamt wurden 150 hänge an
zehn orten untersucht das ergebnis die
mysteriösen
jürgen klopp linie also kurz rsl fliesst
struktur treten tatsächlich nur anhängen
auf die steirer sind als 27 grad dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher alfred
mcewen
zudem enden alle diese tricks strukturen
auf böschungen die winkel aufweisen wie
sie dem dynamischen verhalten von
abrutschenden trockenen sand auf bühnen
sowohl auf der erde als auch auf dem
mars entsprechen eine struktur die vom
vergleichsweise größeren wassermengen
verursacht wurde
sollte sich hingegen über diese hinaus
ausbreiten
diese übereinstimmung mit den merkmalen
von abrutschenden trockenen sand können
einfach kein zufall sein
doch wirklich seriösen fliesst
strukturen genau entstehen erklärt auch
die aktuelle studie nicht wirklich und
so schließt auch dieses
forschungsergebnis nicht aus dass
eventuell doch kleinste mengen an wasser
auf dem mars vorhanden sein könnten dies
würde auch die ablagerungen der salze
erklären die in bereits vorherigen
studien als handfester hinweis für
fließendes wasser galt auch die nasa hat
sich zu dem aktuellen forschungsergebnis
geäußert sie bezieht sich eben auf die
gefundenen salz spuren und auch auf das
saisonale auftreten der vlis strukturen
beide entdeckungen könnten nicht alleine
durch handbewegungen erklärt werden und
die nase ergänzt zudem die ergebnisse
die in nature geoscience veröffentlicht
wurden sprechen dagegen dass genügend
flüssiges wasser vorhanden ist dann mit
mikrobiellen leben an diesen standorten
existieren kann
es gibt zudem überlegungen obwohl hinter
diesen regierungslinie mechanismen
stecken die uns noch unbekannt sind weil
sie eventuell nur so auf dem mars geht
bridge zurück von der nasa fast den
status quo so zusammen
der neue bericht sagt das rsl nicht nass
genug sind damit mobiles leben
existieren könnte
es sind untersuchungen vor ort mit
speziellen verfahren erforderlich dabei
muss die einschleppung von mikroben von
der erde verhindert werden denn noch
immer fehlt eine vollständige erklärung
wie sich diese rätselhafte merkmale
verdummt können und verblassen
ja wenn ihr kein video zu möglichem
leben auf dem mars und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
durch mir hier ein abo aufsaugen und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
denn nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über
neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dafür drauf klicken
außer dieses leben auf dem mars neue
indizien ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran